hi i'm miles i'm going to show you how i
professionally clean an indoor pool
which hasn't been used for six years
all right then had a dm come through can
i help sort out this pool
which actually looks more like a pond i
know i was half expecting to see a fish
swimming around in the bottom there was
plants growing in there like pond plants
they thought maybe like like when they
were cutting the grass and they had the
doors open maybe little bits blew in and
like seeds or whatever just went into
the water and see bits start growing and
stuff so maybe like that but who knows
we're gonna empty and clean out
dropping in the submersible pump first
and we'll be back the next day
nice and empty but not nice and clean
time to get to work i'm gonna jump in
and have a look at the damage first
yeah so once the port was empty um
we brushed them in into a corner of a
mask with a big brush and
shoved them out into a bucket and threw
on their compost heap the main
difference between cleaning indoor and
outdoor pool is
normally you don't get any sort of
debris in an indoor pool
obviously this one had plants growing in
it took about five five or six years for
this pool to get like that but for an
outdoor pool that'd probably only take
maybe a year year and a half for it to
get like that stay
so before we emptied the pool this was
actually floating so when we emptied it
sort of like the plants had like started
attaching themselves to the wall
then jet washing the walls on the floor
quickly have a guess of what pictures
tiled in on the floor
i went for a dolphin
turns out it's a sea lion that's pretty
cool though
it's coming up nicely but there's still
some stains left over so what we're
going to do is mix up some acid in a
bucket of water
scrub that all over the floor and walls
then we're going to jet wash the
surround
jump back in the pool
rinse that down
get the big hoover out start hoovering
up all the last little bits
[Music]
um so that is
a chlorine dispenser and you can fill
that up with the chlorine tablets
and it slowly dissolves the tablets
feeding chlorine into the pool
you could fill up the chlorine feeder
with the tablets but it won't give your
poor instant chlorine you'd then put in
the granules to give it
that initial
chlorine dose and then the tablets will
slowly dissolve bringing out the
chlorine level as well
that is um
well some people think it's me adding
color to the pool
is that what makes the pool look blue is
what some people
message me but actually it's algaecide
and that is to prevent
the growth of algae
so that is a jelly cube
and
it's a
water clarifier
also it removes phosphates from the pool
um and helps with chemical efficiency
what it does is help with like a layer
pick up small particles therefore making
the poor bit clearer
but when you initially put salt
in a pool
a freshly filled pool it will take
around a week
for the salt
to be generated into
chlorine itself and the process is
called electrolysis
it looked as if it had just been
finished from like new build
the tiles were like nice and blue nice
and white tiles very clean looking
um
100 times better than what it did when i
turned up this was all within
maybe half a day's work
i've seen green indoor pools but never
an indoor pool with anything growing
other than a little bit of algae